okay I wanted to tell you about the
number 2084 it arises at the end of a
little story this particular one came
about on a chess board for this is a
really big chess board this is an
infinite board and so I'm gonna number
the squares so I'll start off I'll pick
any square and number at one and now we
work in a spiral around it and we number
them it's called a square spiral when we
row around and around around till we
filled up the whole board now what we do
is we take a knight an ordinary chess
night and we start him off at square
number one and now we look at all the
squares that he can jump to the knight
could move from 1 to 12
or from 1 to 18 the rule is we always go
to the smallest square and we can't
repeat a square we have to always go to
a new square so from 1 it looks like to
me like we could get to 10 there are
eight squares and 10 is the smallest so
we're going to get a sequence which is
the sequence of the squares where the
night goes to sum starts off at 1 his
first move is to the smallest number
that it can go to there they've hasn't
already been to so it can go to 10 from
10 ah it can move back to 3 so 10 goes
to 3 so the third term in the sequence
is 3 then from 3 we could go to 6 6 is
obviously the next number and then 9 4
so that's the sequence we do that
forever it would be nice if we could do
it forever but something strange happens
after we've been going on for a long
time it gets trapped in fact after 2016
steps it must it gets stuck it cannot
move every square every one of the eight
squares around it that it could move to
it's already been 2 so it died the
sequence dies at that point after 2016
steps and the last number that it
reaches is 2084 and I have in my note
here a picture of the spiral so you can
see it starts off here and the colors it
gets lighter and lighter as it starts
off fairly dark and then we have blue
and green and yellow around there are
very strange long lines of points where
it moves in a straight line this night
moving two and one two and one and so on
but eventually it gets to this red dot
and there it gets stuck all of the eight
squares it could possibly move to it's
already visited it's deliciously
arbitrary isn't an unexpected that it
could it you would have thought some
pattern or system had emerged where oh
it's gonna go forever now yeah it's
wonderful yeah this surprises me I think
it's wonderful it's it's yeah it's a
strange sequence the missing numbers
that that's another sequence so if we
look at the ones it doesn't visit there
are infinitely many that's an infinite
sequence and the smallest one it doesn't
get to is 961 you can do it without the
chess pieces you can do it with a castle
a rook you could do it on a chess board
of a different shape you could do it on
the kind of chess board that you get if
you just just one quadrant once one
quarter of the infinite board so let's
pretend we have our chess board and we
number the squares just as we did in the
spiral here we're gonna number them in
along diagonals more precisely along
anti-diagonal
two three and so on
you play the same game one and what's
the smallest square it can move to well
it can only move to eight or nine so it
has to go to the smaller of them so the
sequence goes one eight and now from
eight we could move to some big numbers
here but the smallest number is
obviously six so one eight six and then
to two and then to twelve it looks like
and so on so one eight six to twelve
again the sequence is finite at step
2402 it reaches one three seven eight
and there are no squares it can move -
it dies at that point again it's
color-coded it starts off in the corner
and as the trajectory moves along it
gets the colors get lighter and lighter
and you see that red X there that's
where it gets trapped you love it don't
you I do yeah
so you can do the same thing with a rook
with a queen it doesn't get stuck keeps
going do you play chess no not anymore I
retired I retired at the age of 14 it
was taking up too much time well I
didn't start this till I was in grad
school everyone have a look at this and
this and how about this these are just
some of the quizzes and puzzles and
questions you'll find on brilliant which
is a sponsor of today's episode now I've
met some of the people that work at
brilliant they're real science math
people and they take it really seriously
these courses these quizzes these
questions they're designing they're
really well thought out they really
think about how to design these in such
a way that people like you who are doing
them are gonna be smarter they really
want to change the way you think now
there's lots of stuff on the brilliant
site that's free but numberphile viewers
can also get a 20% discount on a premium
membership which has got even more good
stuff by going to brilliant org slash
numberphile and now thanks to brilliant
for supporting this episode why don't
you go and check him out there's also a
link down in the description
[Music]